you know when i was a kid my two younger
sisters used to sometimes speak to each
other in a secret language they had made
up they claimed that they had invented a
whole new
dialect with its own unique words and
sentence structures and
rules of grammar it was pretty clear to
me at the time even more clear to me now
looking back in hindsight that they were
just babbling gibberish to each other
and primarily doing it to annoy me and
they succeeded
and i sometimes reflect on those more
innocent times and and i think about how
my annoyance would have turned into
crushing despair had i known
what sort of world i would find myself
in as an adult if only i had known that
i would one day live in a society where
lots of people
have invented their own secret gibberish
languages and that we would all be
expected to listen to this gobbledygook
and take it seriously and even speak it
ourselves
i think if someone had told me that
or told me like anything else about
modern society i would have simply
gotten on a boat and set sail into the
pacific
and found a remote island somewhere far
away and isolated
and lived out the rest of my days there
in fact this is an option that i'm still
actively considering even now especially
after seeing things like this time
magazine
attempting to win the nobel prize in
virtue signaling
published an interview last night with
the author of a pornography book called
genderqueer and we'll have more on that
book later on but they tweeted a link to
the article with this caption
this is what it says
time spoke to genderqueer author and
illustrator maya kobe on about about air
work the efforts to restrict access to
air writing and what a make of the
current cultural moment
now those aren't typos though it would
be impossible to tell if they were
these are rather the pronouns that the
author maya identifies as
this is made clear in the article itself
reading just a small portion of it it
says maya kobe felt a wave of relief on
tuesday morning waking up on the west
coast and early morning peak at emails
revealed a virginia court had dismissed
a lawsuit seeking to label kobe's book
genderqueer as obscene and restricted
sale to minors in virginia
the suit was among the latest in an
onslaught of challenges to kobe's memoir
which was the most challenged book of
2021 according to the american library
association in the 2019 illustrated
graphic memoir kobabe who uses e m air
pronouns
explores air process of coming out as
non-binary and asexual kobe 33 isn't the
only author to face serious new
challenges to air material according to
research by pen america a non-profit
organization to advocate for free
expression 1 145 books by 874 different
authors were banned from school
libraries and classrooms between july 1
2021 and march 31st 2022
in the wake of cobaib's win in virginia
time spoke with the author and
illustrator about air work the efforts
to restrict access to air writing and
what a makes of the current cultural
moment now
it may sound like uh a spelled e-y would
be like the fonz's personal pronoun but
the fonz lived before our society had
one big collective stroke and started
babbling nonsensically to each other
these are rather non-binary pronouns
uh so-called neo pronouns which is to
say that they are words
maya simply invented in her troubled
head and now demands we all use in
reference to her
the argument often put forward in
defense of neo pronouns is that
although they're made up
well so is every other word in the
english language
this is this this same talking point has
been trotted out today by those looking
to defend time magazine
but
of course it isn't true
the english language is learned
not made up
as far as you're concerned okay you
didn't invent the english language
neither did i we don't leave
children alone to come up with their own
words for everything and then slap the
label of english onto whatever they come
up with
we teach them what words are and what
they mean
now it's true obviously that every word
we speak was at some point in the past
formulated right
made up if that's how you want to put it
but
this follows a logical process
and the words all mean something and
that meaning is understood and shared by
everyone who speaks the language these
are the two iron-clad rules of language
it must mean something to be a word and
it must be shared it must be a shared
meaning
if i if either two of these rules are
not followed you don't have a language
you have gibberish
and by insisting that each person can
simply come up with their own words and
that those words
don't need to really mean anything at
all
the left is not proposing changes to the
english language neither are they
helping it to evolve they are instead
destroying it breaking it down
demolishing it
which is what they do to literally
everything
let me look at it like this
the sentence
please pass the salt
contains four words
now
each of those words came into being at
some point in the past
they weren't invented by one single
identifiable person
okay but but rather they they formed and
evolved in a logical and understandable
way there's a whole field of study
called etymology which examines exactly
this process of linguistic evolution
but if i were to one day simply decide
that instead of saying please pass the
salt i am going to say gabaguda flabadi
everyone else at the dinner table would
look at me confused and assume that i'm
either demonically possessed or
attempting a very bad impression of a
90s era adam sandler
that's because i cannot just decide on
my own to replace existing words with
with words that have logical
etymological or origins with random
sounds that i came up with that's not
how language works
and yet even this example at the dinner
table does not capture
the absurdity of the left's pronoun
nonsense because at least in the case of
the dinner table i can tell you what my
gibberish means it means past the salt
but the person with the neo pronoun
can't explain what it means because it
means nothing
what does it mean to be an em heir what
is that nobody can tell us nobody can
explain it
because it's simply nonsense it's
nonsense all the way down it's nonsense
on top of nonsense on top of nonsense
and when you get to the bottom of the
stack of nonsense you find nothing
you're just hovering in in abyss
it is a made up word which symbolizes
nothing
nothing that is other than the
overwhelming narcissism of the
individual who uses it
i mean whatever else the non-binary
binary person quote-unquote claims to be
communicating with her pronouns what
she's really conveying
is that she is pretentious
and self-absorbed in the extreme that's
what all of these pronouns really mean
it means i am incredibly incredibly
self-absorbed
now there may be something else going on
here too as i was thinking about it it's
possible
that part of the strategy with the neo
pronoun
is to make the left's other attempts at
language manipulation seem less extreme
by comparison right maybe they're
pretending to try to get us to use e m
air or z zem zebra or whatever so that
we'll throw up our hands and agree to
call a man she or a woman he
so long as they just leave it at that
you know maybe that's the idea because
like in in reality
no one is actually going to use those
pronouns no one no normal person nobody
is going to go around saying em air no
one's gonna do that and they must know
that no one's going to do it so maybe
part of the idea is all right well if
you won't do this
then at least do the other the this
other pronoun stuff
my kids sometimes use a similar strategy
you know they'll come up and say hey
daddy uh can you buy us a grenade
launcher
what no i can't i can't okay well then
can we just have ice cream at least
and this might be part of the idea
though i may be doing the left an
undeserved favor by assuming that
they're as clever as you know my
nine-year-olds
and yet
we've been so hung up on
the gibberish
that we haven't even discussed the book
that this person wrote and that might be
another part of the plan here
this is the book that time magazine is
promoting
that book genderqueer
is a work of outright pornography
with content so explicit and outrageous
that i can't i can't show it to you and
i can't even describe it
to you
suffice it to say that there are
explicit images of various sex acts
along with scenes so depraved that you
you couldn't even anticipate them
so if you're imagining like what what a
pornographic book might consist of yeah
it consists of a lot of that kind of
stuff but then also stuff that you
wouldn't even think of it's like just
one example which fair warning this is
highly disgusting and disturbing so but
i this is one that i will describe to
you
there is one scene
in which the author depicts a
conversation with her sister
where the sister suggests that she'd
taste her own vaginal discharge
and then we're shown a panel with her
finger covered in that discharge now i
told you it's disgusting
but at the same time as much as we want
to cover our ears and say i don't even
want to hear about this
these are the books they're putting in
schools they're putting these in schools
for little kids to read
and what i just described to you is one
of the less graphic moments of the book
it was like one of the only moments i
could even describe
putting it in schools across the country
for kids
and and when normal decent people
object to this sort of content being
used to educate children
the left cries out in horror claiming
censorship and fascism if you don't want
explicit pornography taught to your kid
in school like it's literature
then you're a fascist
now all in all
this whole story perfectly encapsulates
our cultural moment the entire thing
from the pronouns down to the book right
because it's inane nonsense on the
surface that's the em air pronouns
nonsense on the surface and then when
you look beneath the surface what you
find is vile hideous evil filth
now the good news if we can
call it good news if there can be any
good news
is that the nonsense is so nonsensical
and the hideous evil is so hideous and
so evil that the left is forcing people
to finally make a choice
like there is no neutral ground anymore
that time has long since passed
are you going to run around babbling
absolute gibberish
at the behest of narcissists intoxicated
by the stench of their own farts are you
going to do that are you actually going
are you willing to do that
even if up until this moment you were
the sort of person who said i just want
to be polite and i want to get along
with you and it doesn't hurt me if they
want me to use the pronoun
really yeah i mean it doesn't physically
actually it would physically pain me to
use those pronouns in a non-ironic way
but maybe it wouldn't physically hurt
you yet are you really gonna do that
are you going to keep a spreadsheet
maybe carry a clipboard around with a
spreadsheet keeping track of all the
gibberish words that each person that
you know each ego maniacal narcissist
you know demands you use and before you
refer to them or about them uh you know
refer to that clip art are you going to
do that
are you going to tolerate literal
pornography being taught as literature
to children in school
or are you going to finally draw the
line
and say no more
i've had enough
this is it
no
you can cry about it okay you could say
your feelings are hurt
you can call me a bigot i don't care the
answer is no stop talking
stop demanding no
are you gonna say that
that's the choice they're forcing
it's a it's a time of deciding
i know my answer is
you have to decide what yours is
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts